dozens of massachusetts state troopers
handing in their badges over the state's
vaccine mandate set to kick in on
october 17th with law enforcement
already critically understaffed
nationwide is this putting the public in
even more danger mike shervin is a is
the president of the state police
association of massachusetts and a
25-year veteran of the force and he
joins us now good morning to you
good morning good morning sergeant why
are you fed up
well there just hasn't been time uh to
properly roll this program out uh we are
in the middle of impact bargaining the
deadlines are here upon us and we don't
have the answers that our members need
those that are seeking medical and
religious exemptions uh have not been
told if they're granted will they be
allowed a reasonable alternative to it
to wear a mask and weekly testing
and because of that they're looking to
other places for employment in the
municipal departments within the state
of massachusetts are offering these
reasonable alternatives so it's not an
across-the-board mandate it's only for
the executive branch of massachusetts
which is affecting my membership so
state troopers are now taking jobs in
municipalities where they just get
tested and they have to wear masks right
that's correct for the for the number
that uh that have for whatever reason
not received their vaccination they are
choosing uh and they've submitted their
their letters of intent they have not
officially resigned
following the policy to notify the
department within 30 days
of their intent to leave how many state
troopers are we talking about what
percentage
i i can't give you a percentage right
now we're still within that 30-day
window which was actually
changed by the department to allow for
14 days but i'm very comfortable in
stating that it's dozens how do you feel
about these mandates i mean you guys
have been heroes and have done this
successfully for the last 18 months
this doesn't come down to uh the
feelings for the mandate for us this is
about fair labor practices and making
sure that our members that that have
been on the front lines can remain on
the front lines and years of experience
doesn't walk out the door and you did
file a lawsuit and what did the judge
say
the judge denied the lawsuit we were
looking for an extension of
of the executive order to allow us to
continue to impact bargaining here's
your governor this is charlie baker
um i think it's critically important for
those folks to get vaccinated which is
the reason why
we made the decision to require
everybody who works in the executive
branch to get vaccinated there have been
some pretty significant retirements in
the state police over the course of the
past couple years
i think some of that is demography we'll
have to continue to to work hard with
our folks at
the mass state police and our folks in
the legislature to make sure we fund
classes and that we recruit aggressively
to refill the ranks what's your reaction
well the unfortunate part there is yes
years of
of neglect if you will for not having
classes and keeping up with our numbers
we are down to the lowest that i can
recall in my 25-year uh history where uh
a recent call-in study suggested we
should be at 2 900 troopers we're now
dipping about to dip below 2 000.
i don't know how we're going to make up
these numbers and that's prior to uh the
the possible exodus of dozens of
troopers for this mandate wow and how is
that going to affect the community and
people when they need to stay safe and
we rely on you to keep us safe
thank you so much it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate we're not going to be
able to uh determine how that is going
to affect us but we're going to see an
increase in caseload in the uh response
times and overwork well thank you for
all that you're doing you guys are here
as we appreciate it you're welcome